deux ont excusé aujourd'hui on se
retrouve pour la troisième fois sur une
gamme d or les simulateurs y ait une
mise à jour avec des trucs très très con
quoi pourra faire c'est parti direction
l'école sous les mollahs défendent avec
kidnapper une fille est là on va faire
bien pire
la première de voter non on pas noyer
quelqu'un brut un bordel
exactement comme ça devant devant tout
le monde
bonjour non mais vas-y l'espace me
croyez en les gars on joue on se
chamaille
aux usa les emballer dans le cul vous
c'est ça faut que j'apprenne que j'ai
appris que j'allais cacher comme ça il y
aura plus de preuves d'une évidence
contre moi mais il faut bien s'y faire
avant que la prof arrive à l'arrivée
d'arriver là où y'a rien là rien madame
je me cachais les assez tard dans le
doute mais c'est pas moi vous voyez bien
car rien n'est pas m'accuser quoi bien
rien du tout alors c'était juste une
blague je pense pas que c'est très drôle
de meute ne me fais plus jamais perdre
mon temps comme saab alors tu es des
congas tdi kabuki quo ante et les
goûters bla tda goûté à ça commence à
suffire vient bon voila vous l'aurez
compris on peut maintenant noyer des
gens dont la fontaine ce qui est
formidable j'ai redémarré le jour parce
que j'avais vraiment la firme nettoyer
tout ce sang aujourd'hui j'avais pas
envie de faire le ménage à la fois la
réputation [ __ ] bonjour non pas deux
mais bien pour toi il vous [ __ ] toi
mon gars aulas tu es très belle
en plus j'ai dit qu'à toi j'ai dis à
personne d'autre donc là c'est la pause
déjeuner tout le monde veille sur le
toit et non en mer mais [ __ ] faut pas
trop à gauche 7e pareil logiquement il
ya deux filles qui vont aller parler un
petit peu en tête à tête vers là-bas il
me semble j'espère ne pas me voir et que
tout ce que je fais foire généralement
dans les airs et simulateurs on va voir
allez dis moi qui est de fait qui
viennent parler oui oui oui je dis oui
on va ces coupures comme ça ll faut
parler entrée voilà deux choses un petit
peu entre meilleurs amis y en a une qui
veut dire ya quelque chose qui a pas
chez transmanche trouve est là elle
vient de répondre non réa tu veux pas en
parler ya pas de soucis mais souviens
toi je suis son ami je ne jugerai jamais
pour quoi que ce soit ok j'avoue il ya
un truc dont j'aimerais parler depuis
que ma mère est morte
mon père boit beaucoup des fois quand il
a vu il vient dans ma chambre et au nom
puisque je viens de dire je veux
vraiment pas en parler quoi mais ça a
l'air vraiment sérieuse des coudes j'ai
dit que je voulais plus en parler vespa
ton qu'il hockey au but à elle car mais
lunatique peu à aulas l'ariège leur fait
le coup vous savez le hop là il tombe
non alors là ce qui est cool c'est que
du coup j'ai trouvé le point fait de la
filière a malheureusement c'est le truc
le plus glauque du monde et du coup
maintenant je veux aller à son casier et
ouais et vu que jérémy des points dans
la capacité langage et ben je vais
pouvoir laisser une petite note sur son
casier
voilà regarder livnat là je laisse une
lettre disant je veux te parler à propos
bah domestique abuse du coup s'il te
plaît vient me voir sur le toit à quatre
heures oh la la c'est tellement fou bon
gars on retourne en cours plus tard
c'est tellement ce titre les buts et
comme sa manière différente c'est moi
voilà c'est la fin des cours tout le
monde va se donner rendez vous aux
casiers pour récupérer ses petites
affaires
oh mon dieu à le voir qu'est ce que
c'est il peut être que je devrais le
rencontrer allez viens sur le toit le
suspense est terrible
notre coeur bat à fond ah oui elle est
un peu de retard [ __ ] c'est minutes
j'y croyais plus on te suit intentions
et là on arrive par derrière et on lui
fait je m'en bats les c
voilà et là j'ai mis une lettre de
suicide sur ses chaussures vais vite me
barrer avant quelqu'un me prenne sur le
toit avec les mains qui sentent épiés
sait comment être bien grillé non j'ai
pas de chez ses chaussures rouges en mer
et je rentre à la maison
j'aime pas que mais posera un jour le
jour d'école c'est terminé les profs
doivent faire le tour de l'école pour
dire à tout élève y est encore de
rentrer chez lui pendant qu'il
inspectait un prof a découvert un corps
c'est pas tout ça semble être un
étudiant qui s'est suicidé les mamans de
l'école se sont mis d'accord pour
appeler la police et les mettre au
courant de la mort de l'étudiant au nom
pourquoi la police sera mais dans cette
histoire
[ __ ] la police a été incapable de
découvrir des preuves qui auraient
montré que la mort de l'étudiant était
en fait un meurtre la police en a conclu
que l'étudiant a mis fin à ses jours
lui-même selpak tué bientôt aux années
où nous sommes maintenant youtube the
five of april to stardom sixtine comme
quand notre prof nous demander de
marquer la date au tableau quand vous
souvenez alors est-ce qu'il y en a une
qui va aller aux toilettes cette fois
parce que normalement on peut faire un
truc cool
pourquoi personne ne va aux toilettes
allait elle est bien l'une entre vous
qu'elle avait six plein là sans déconner
toi tu va me suivre je vais te vider la
vessie moi même [ __ ] voulait pas
l'auto l'aide c'est moi qui vais vous y
emmener allait bien là attendant on va
et dans celle des hommes bien via
l'egypte et à saint-palais pas l'habitat
ce serait con le voir en urinoir on va
essayer de fermer la porte derrière elle
ah mais non mais non attends moi la hâte
en hôpital devient folle as tu en voilà
deux verres follet qu'apporte permis
s'il te plaît est ce que t'as pas envie
de pisser épices bordel mais elle veut
pas uriner mais c'est pas possible ça
mais elle me saoule
elle me [ __ ] j'ai pas pris de couteau
aurait planté là c'est la pause du midi
j'ai mis des points dans la bille dans
la echl yeux dans la chimie je crois est
en fait normalement ça va me permettre
voilà d'aller dans cette pièce est de
trouver du [ __ ] poison hop on le prend
au semaine à comme sa mère très discrète
normalement quelqu'un va finir par
lasser mbaye ndiaye the grudge quoi
pourquoi personne ne vient par lahcen
sbaï non c'est une blague non et du coup
vous que les autorités en accélérer cela
va faire immortal cours non me punit
sais pas si tu n'es pas l'un de mes
élèves
ah bon mais je trouve cette classe
excusez moi un moment gênant bonjour au
revoir
voilà oui si tu as dû m'acquitter crains
s'il te plaît essaye d'arriver en cours
à leurs attentes mais de tuer même pas
les attentes sait pas qui on est je le
mets de la physical education et je te
défonce avec mes gros biceps le bal est
le couteau à la main je m'en bats les
steaks moi tu vas faire non non pardon
non tu vas faire que tu vas faire un
tueur faire ah non tu faisais là non
mais attends fait les gens arrivent à 7
heures à l'école mais les cours
commencent à 8 heures ça s'appelle une
heure de colle mais ils sont tous cas
alors on va retourner prendre le petit
laboratoire
le petit poison et on va tenter l'on
présente mais pourquoi normalement il ya
une fille qui doit venir et qui doit
poser un plateau avec de la bouffe
quelque part peut-être que j'ai pas vu
mais mes et
saint pie est en position est
normalement normalement d'accord on est
d'accord personne d'imposer sa bouffe
qui est par là maintenant je serai pas
une psychopathe comme ça sème pas été un
peu gentil avec moi à l'aller m'ignore
il ment il s'en fout de moi ok j'ai le
poison il manque plus que la bouffe dans
lequel nous sommes honnêtes je vois
toutes les portes pour vraiment ayant
elle est grandement envie de venir
oui oui oui va par là s'aiment pas et
c'est ça tu n'auras jamais été qu'une je
vous dirai comment je me sens
elle a prévu lui dire ce qu'elle ressent
pour lui vendredi avant fait elle même
pas eu parler l'observer quoi vas-y
bouffe ben vas-y je t'en prie aubin
enfin je crois que tu vas pas de lui
dire grand chose qu'est ce qui t'a verte
en train d'y goûter parker gigoter
j'appelle ça depuis si longtemps bas
alors on est des gains à hope là qu'est
ce qui t'arrive
ils sont allés chercher un prof temps je
me cassais mort amène moi jusqu'à lui ok
donc ils lui ont dit qu'ils avaient vu
quelqu'un qui est décédé moi j'ai rien
fait moi j'étais sousse banques comme ça
pour pas que les autres me frappe ce que
tous les jours les gens il me frappe
attends mon gars le prof n'est jamais
venu et en plus en retard en cours ou
c'est quoi ce délire qui au retard oui
je peux pas les en cours parce que le
corps est visible oui mais en attendant
au risque à deux chiffres des points
dans l'éducation physique doit on est
content alors il ya aussi un beau succès
les easter egg là où vous savez il ya le
mode l'attaqué des titans qu'on peut
activer apparemment il ya aussi d'autres
modes
il faut trouver la touche ah c'est bon
j'ai trouvé center mode elle est
terrifiante mondial où rim
qu'est-ce qui a pas avec toi pourquoi
t'es pourquoi tu es si blizzard hehe
vas-y celle de rakaka talons hauts elle
est terrifiante pour gars c'est chiant
oh [ __ ] j'ai tellement pas envie de
voir ça chez moi un jour sème pas je
m'en bats les steaks de toi là aussi tu
es sympa que tu es s'appelle bien être
est ce que je te bute est la preuve et
la vengeance d'une vie la jeunesse
oui ou non mais la manière est center
non mais un moment bonne chose mode
aller non mais là j'ai mille fois plus
de cas est que toutes les autres filles
rêvaient dit quoi senpai ne peut pas
pêcher ou quelqu'un d'autre
gallo mode
bonjour cette paille comment ça va et
s'il va pas avec soin mais vas-y je te
baise des cas mode c'est quoi ça dd si
gros bras squeeze rêve d'avoir les mêmes
lafitte civile avec des bras comme ça ça
passe pas du tout quoi on avait plutôt
qu'elle fait gamme style le mot ou là
j'ai sorti un nom de buzz qui date de
2000 $ il nous reste enfin le 47 marode
agent 47
bonjour comment ça va moi ça va je tue
des gens ça se voit pas et le meilleur
pour la fin
je m'en lasserai jamais alors là tu
recules dans la main c'est pas un katana
c'est un coupe ongle propre petit temps
et je suis très peu fier de cette vanne
brown et j'en suis à 37 troisième vidéo
sur regard guérissent yves lador vous a
pu faire pas mal de trucs lanouaille et
quelqu'un pour empoisonner quelqu'un il
faire un faux suscite c'est quand même
beau jeu soit chose a plus ces cas
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça fera
plaisir à votre firme pike qui veut tous
les tétons j'en profite aussi pour vous
remercier parce que vous avez été super
gentil en voyant le site sortir vous
avez tous eu l'air d'apprécier décidé
vous l'avez tous dit il soit fait super
plaisir
donc voila merci beaucoup c'est super
school school voilà on reste dans le
dans l'école à savoir regarder la vidéo
portez vous bien juteux monde pis